[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrigerin schönen guten Abend zusammen
Norbert Lehmann später mit Hockey
Handball und Rudel damit lauter
spannenden Entscheidungen schönen guten
Abend auch von mir dann schauen wir
jetzt gemeinsam auf die Themen der
Sendung
[Musik]
Gedenken an den Holocaust
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars mahnt die
Erinnerung an alle Opfer der NS-Zeit
wach zu halten
nach Panzern bald auch Kampfjets die
Ukraine bittet den Westen erneut um
Flugzeuge anders sei Russland nicht zu
stoppen
und massiver Lehrermangel in Deutschland
die Länder wollen jetzt Pädagogen aus
dem Ruhestand holen und mehr
Quereinsteiger
[Musik]
anlässlich des Internationalen Holocaust
Gedenktages erinnerte der Bundestag in
einer Gedenkstunde an die Opfer und
dieses Gedenken war dieses Mal etwas
anders
weil der Fokus sollte Menschen galt die
wegen ihrer sexuellen Orientierung
verfolgt wurden auch noch nach Ende des
ns-regims Andreas berichtet
wenn ich mir
georget die interpretiert den jüdischen
Komponisten Friedrich Holländer
musikanischer Beitrag für eine Premiere
der holocaust-gedenkfeier im Bundestag
erstmals wird hier der Menschen gedacht
die wegen ihrer sexuellen Orientierung
von den Nazis verfolgt verhaftet gequält
und getötet worden sind
aus den Lagern befreit wurden auch die
wegen ihrer Sexualität Inhaftierten doch
für sie brachte das Ende des
Nationalsozialismus kein Ende der
staatlichen Verfolgung
in beiden Teilen Deutschlands galt der
Paragraph 175 Strafgesetzbuch nach 1945
weiter so werden bis 1969 rund 50.000
zumeist schwule Männer nach Paragraph
175 strafrechtlich verurteilt auch Klaus
Schirdewahn was macht das mit einem
Menschen der niemand ein Leid angetan
der niemand bedrängt bedroht oder
angegriffen hat
Rosette Katz aus Amsterdam auch
festrednerin heute ihre jüdischen Eltern
geben sie 1943 mit acht Monaten in eine
Pflegefamilie so überlebt sie Vater
Mutter und Bruder werden in Auschwitz
ermordet sie begrüßt ausdrücklich das
endlich auch sexuelle Minderheiten im
Mittelpunkt des Gedenkens stehen wenn
bestimmte Opfergruppen gar nicht weniger
wertvoll als andere angesehen werden
dann bedeutet das am Ende nur eins
dass die nationalsozialistisch sind
Ideologie weiterlebt 1900 es hat Zeit
gebraucht bis man schwulen lesbischen
und quieren naziopfern im Bundestag
endlich auch Anerkennungen
entgegengebracht hat
ja jeder der schon einmal Zeitzeugen
erlebte wie sie über die schlimmsten
Menschheitsverbrechen der Nazis
berichten weiß solche Begegnungen sind
unersetzlich allerdings sind sie immer
seltener möglich nicht nur im Bundestag
gab es jetzt diese Begegnungen Natalie
Steger traf ihn Krakau eine Frau die die
Hölle von Auschwitz als Kind überlebte
lydia maximovic ist erst drei als die
Deutschen sie in die Hölle von Auschwitz
der portieren an manches erinnert sie
sich sagt sie weil es besonders
schrecklich war sie wird von der Mutter
getrennt in die Kinder Baracke gesteckt
sie zwangen mich in eine der Kojen auf
die Pritsche da war eine Decke steil vor
Schmutz und voller Insekten und da saßen
kleines Skelette
kein anderes Kind überlebt in Auschwitz
solange wie sie 13 Monate lang Kinder
die Nacht starben diese Leichen wurden
auf deutschen Befehl herausgezogen sie
wurden von der Liste gestrichen und vor
unseren Augen auf einen Karren geworfen
der zum Krematorium fuhr
Auschwitz das größte
menschenvernichtungslager der Nazis mehr
als eine Million Menschen haben die
Deutschen hier getötet die meisten Opfer
waren Juden Kinder nach der Befreiung
eine von ihnen validia maximovic
Auschwitz heute gedenken an die Opfer
des Holocausts Überlebende gehen den
schweren Weg zurück und auch Jugendliche
aus Deutschland sind dabei
auf jeden Fall das wichtigste ist daran
dass man diese Geschichte nicht vergisst
dass die weitergegeben wird und dass man
auch in Zukunft so was halt sowas nicht
mehr passiert Hunger Qual Opfer von Lage
als Josef Mengeles kinderexperimenten
dennoch ist ledia maximovic versöhnlich
wenn ich hasse und den Wunsch nach Rache
hätte ging es mir schlechter ich könnte
kein normales Leben führen
sagt sie der die Deutschen die Kindheit
raubten
kaum ist die panzerdebatte beendet
deutet sich die nächste Waffen
Diskussion an Ukrain ist Präsident
selensky fordert unter anderem Kampfjets
für sein Land Deutschland schließt das
kategorisch aus anders die USA wir
werden das sorgfältig diskutieren so der
Vize Sicherheitsberater von Präsident
beiden ähnliche stimmen auch aus
Frankreich und Polen mehr von Jürgen
Kiel
russische Kampfjets präsentiert von der
Kreml Propaganda Einsatz über der
Ukraine kein Gegner in sich Raketen
werden abgefeuert mit westlichen Jets
etwa mit der amerikanischen F16 würde
die Ukraine gerne bald zurückschlagen
unrealistisch sagen viele Experten
Pilotenausbildung Logistik sehr
kompliziert
mit westlichen Kampfflugzeugen könnte
die Ukraine sicher aus dem Stegreif
erstmal nichts anfangen aber es ist ja
auch die mit 29 im Gespräch mit der
mig29 ist die Ukraine natürlich sehr gut
vertraut die Piloten und Piloten wissen
sich Wissen des Flugzeug zu bedienen es
gibt entsprechende Logistik die
Ersatzteile sind da und so weiter und so
fort Bulgarien und vor allem Polen
könnten die mit Jäger liefern aus alten
DDR-Beständen deshalb müssten auch hier
die deutschen ihrer Erlaubnis geben ein
Problem die Flieger bräuchten in der
Ukraine auch sichere Flughäfen können
die Basen überhaupt geschützt werden
gegen konzentrierte russische
Luftangriffe denn die operationsfreiheit
für die ukrainische Luftwaffe besteht ja
nur eine ganz gering es ist richtig das
Russland ist nicht geschafft hat die
Luftherrschaft zu gewinnen aber die Luft
Überlegenheit haben sie halt immer noch
im dornbas halten die Ukraine die
Stellung Bilder direkt von der Front von
tschechischen Fernsehen neue Munition
ist gekommen neue Kampfflugzeuge aus dem
Westen die Entlastung bringen könnten
sind wohl erstmal nicht in Sicht
ich glaube dass wir da
so so schnell zumindest keine
Entscheidung bekommen sondern dass die
Bedenken auch was eskalationsrisiken
betrifft aber auch was die Macht die
technische Machbarkeit betrifft
überwiegend werden so tobte Krieg in der
Ukraine wohl erstmal weiter am Boden im
Donbass brennt das Städtchen Wuhle da
vor einer Woche noch war es vom Kampf
unberührt
zurück zur kampfpanzerfrage unter
anderem dazu gibt es spannende
Ergebnisse im neuen ZDF Politbarometer
Matthias frohnhoff ist bei mir hallo
Matthias was sagen denn die Befragten
zur Lieferung von Leopard kampfmannstern
die Zustimmung die ist gewachsen seit
entschieden ist und begründet wurde eine
Mehrheit von 54% findet die Lieferung
der Leopard 2 richtig
38% finden das nicht richtig deutliche
Unterstützung bei den Anhängern der
Regierungsparteien und denen der Union
klare Ablehnung bei den afd-anhängern
und mehrheitlich auch bei den Anhängern
der Linken
sehr unterschiedlich ist dabei die
Haltung Invest und Ostdeutschland im
Westen finden 59% die Lieferung der
Kampfpanzer richtig im Osten finden das
57% falsch das ist wirklich interessant
Matthias die panzerfrage die wo die auch
innerhalb der Bundesregierung kontrovers
mit viel Druck geführt wie wir das
bewertet die Außenwirkung der Ampel die
war Nachteils heftigen Streit nicht
besonders gut deshalb glauben
59%, dass das Verhältnis in der
Koalition schlecht ist trotzdem erwartet
eine klare Mehrheit von
71%, dass die Regierung halten wird bis
zur regulären Bundestagswahl 2025
wenn am Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre käme
die SPD auf 21 Prozent plus eins
cdu/csu 27 grüne 19-2 FDP 6 AFD 15 plus
1 linke 6%
. das würde knapp reichen für eine große
Koalition aus Union und SPD und deutlich
für Jamaika für Jamaika also Union mit
Grünen und FDP dann Matthias vielen Dank
für diesen Vorgeschmack ja das gesamte
ZDF Politbarometer das gibt's dann heute
Abend im heute journal um 10 Uhr oder
aber jederzeit online unter ZDF heute.de
bzw in unserer App
das 49 euro-ticket kommt voraussichtlich
zum ersten Mal auf dieses Datum haben
sich die Verkehrsminister von Bund und
Ländern geeinigt der Verkauf der
bundesweiten Monatskarte für den
Regionalverkehr der soll schon am
dritten April beginnen die EU-Kommission
muss dem Ticket noch zustimmen
die Not in Schulen ist groß und das wird
auch wohl die nächsten Jahre so bleiben
es gibt eine dramatischen Lehrermangel
was dagegen tun dazu hat eine
Expertengruppe den Kultusministern
Vorschläge vorgelegt bundesweit melden
die Länder mehr als 12.000 unbesetzte
Lehrerstellen allerdings ist der Mangel
da sehr unterschiedlich verteilt am
meisten Lehrer fehlen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen mehr als 8000
Stellen sind dort unbesetzt andere
Länder wie Hessen oder Rheinland-Pfalz
melden keine einzige unbesetzte Stelle
die Gewerkschaften kritisieren all diese
Zahlen als schön gerechnet Hans Jürgen
Kiel
Geometrie und Matheunterricht an der
Berliner Christian Morgenstern
Grundschule der Lehrer ist promovierter
Politologe aufs Lehramt studiert er
nebenbei Quereinsteiger als Verstärkung
weil es gerade in den Klassenstufen fünf
bis zehn akuten Lehrermangel gibt
es ein riesigen Notstand
bei mir 14 Lehrkräfte die ich nicht
hätte und ich mit großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht durch gut
ausgebildete normale Lehrkräfte abdecken
könnte
Bildungsexperten haben jetzt
Empfehlungen erarbeitet wie trotzdem
ausreichend unterrichtet werden könnte
Unterstützung durch
quereinsteigerpensionäre und
ausländisches personales darin nur ein
Ratschlag Lehrer könnten auch später in
Rente gehen mehr unterrichten und das
vor größeren Klassen hybridunterricht
mit Videoübertragung würde mehr Schüler
erreichen die auch länger alleine lernen
könnten die Hälfte der Lehrkräfte
arbeitet zudem in Teilzeit zu viel sagen
die wissenschaftlichen Berater der
Kultusminister wir denken dass man auch
hier stärkere Anreize braucht das
Teilzeit Lehrkräfte aufstocken und dass
man auch sehr restriktiv sein sollte mit
den Verträgen die und die die 50% einer
vollen Stelle unterschreiben kritik kam
heute bereits vom Lehrerverband
Streichung von teilzeitmöglichkeiten
zurückfahren der altersermäßigungen das
würde noch mehr Kolleginnen und Kollegen
in den Burnout treiben und einen
früheren Ruhestand und das wäre ja
kontraproduktiv was nun umgesetzt wird
kann jedes Bundesland selbst entscheiden
an der Christian morgenstern-grundschule
stellen Sie sich bereits auf jahrelangen
Lehrermangel ein
jetzt der Blick nach Israel dort wächst
die Sorge vor einer weiteren Eskalation
im Zuge eines anti-terror-einsatzes gab
es gestern eine Razzia im West
jordanland 9 Palästinenser wurden heute
beerdigt die bei dem Einsatz getötet
worden waren in der Nacht feuerten
Verbündete militante Gruppen aus dem
Gazastreifen mindestens fünf Raketen auf
Israel ab nach Militärangaben zerstörten
israelische Kampfflugzeuge daraufhin
eine unterirdische Raketen
Produktionsstätte
heute ist es genau drei Jahre her dass
der erste corona-fall in Deutschland
bestätigt wurde bei einem Mitarbeiter
einer bayerischen Firma der sich bei
einer chinesischen Kollegin angesteckt
hatte seitdem haben sich hierzulande
mindestens 37 Millionen Menschen
infiziert über
165.000 sind an oder mit Corona
gestorben und viele Leiden weiterhin
unter dem sogenannten long koved ein
Phänomen das auch Kinder und Jugendliche
betrifft Anna duder berichtet
Lina Feldhoff trainiert Ausdauer vor
zwei Jahren hatte sie Corona leichte
Symptome die Infektion des längst vorbei
doch lina ist nicht gesund
ja dann fing das halt an mit so
Treppensteigen das wieder schwer fällt
also dass man dann schnell aus der Puste
ist manchmal doch einfach so schnelles
Herzrasen wenn man gelegen hat und
aufgestanden ist zu den körperlichen
Symptomen kommen bald auch kognitive
Probleme auch lesen und lernen fallende
Gymnasiasten immer schwerer die Diagnose
in der Rehaklinik in bruchweiler kämpft
sie gegen die Symptome
anmachen ist viel Physiotherapie
Atemtherapie und Ergotherapie ganz viel
was die Kognition anregt das Risiko im
kindes- und Jugendalter an longkowitz zu
erkranken ist höher bei Mädchen es
erkranken eher Teenager als Kinder
Kinder und Jugendliche mit
Vorerkrankungen sind gefährdeter und die
die einen schweren kovit Verlauf hatten
laut Studien leiden ein bis drei Prozent
der Kinder und Jugendlichen nach der
Infektion an longkowitz es gibt mehr als
200 unspezifische Symptome die auch
anderen Krankheiten zu geöffnet werden
können deswegen finden die kleinen
Patienten nicht immer Gehör wenn jemand
der Manager ist der voll im Leben steht
sagt er kommt nicht mehr in die zweite
dritte Etage hoch beim Treppensteigen
dann wird die Person ernst genommen ist
das ein 15-jähriges Mädchen hatte viel
mehr damit zu kämpfen die muss ihre
Eltern überzeugen die muss den
Kinderarzt überzeugen sechs Wochen
bleibt Lina in der Rehaklinik ob Ihre
Symptome in dieser Zeit besser werden
kann niemand sagen
die Gewerkschaft Verdi macht im
Tarifkonflikt mit der Deutschen Post
weiter Druck mit Bahnstreik sie forderte
15% mehr Lohn für 160.000 Beschäftigte
auch das Personal in Hamburg legte die
Arbeit nieder die Post will den
Mitarbeitenden bei der nächsten
Verhandlungsrunde Anfang Februar ein
Angebot machen am Flughafen Düsseldorf
wurde heute ein Drittel der 290 Flüge
gestrichen wegen eines Verdi Streiks bei
der Flugzeug und Gepäck Abfertigung
tumultartige Szenen gestern Abend vor
dem Kreistag von Nordwestmecklenburg
hunderte Menschen protestierten gegen
eine geplante Flüchtlingsunterkunft nach
Polizeiangaben eskalierte die Situation
als ein Teil von ihnen versuchte sich
Zutritt zum kreistagsgebäude zu
verschaffen und mehrfach Pyrotechnik
zündete darunter sein auch bekannte
Rechtsextremisten aus Grevesmühlen Anja
campinos
sie tragen ihren Protest bis unmittelbar
vor den Kreistag von Nordwestmecklenburg
die Polizei verhindert das Eindringen
ins Gebäude drinnen beschließt das
Gremium eine neue Unterkunft für
geflüchtete draußen rund 700 Gegner der
Großteil friedlich laut Polizei aber
auch 170 gewaltbereite Rechtsextreme
Reichsbürger und Hooligans aus der
Region das versucht wird den Kreis das
Saal eines demokratisch gewählten
Kreistages
gegen den Widerstand der Beteiligten zu
betreten in dem Moment sind wir also
Sachverhalten die gar nicht gehen und
bei den der Rechtsstaat auch sehr klar
prüfen wird was dann strafrechtlichen
Sanktion dranhängen muss ein Extremismus
Forscher sieht eine neue Form und
Vorgehen rechtsextremer weg von dem sie
von
Situationen hin zu symbolträchtigen
Angriffen auf die Demokratie das
beobachten wir sehr wohl in opal bei
Grevesmühlen soll ein Containerdorf für
400 geflüchtete vornehmlich aus syr
Afghanistan und Iran entstehen dagegen
regt sich Protest in der Gemeinde mit
rund 1.600 Einwohnern die neue
Unterkunft sei für den Kreis die einzige
Möglichkeit geflüchtete angemessen
unterzubringen so der Landratsamt
sollen wir haben sie in Sporthallen in
der nächsten Woche mache ich eine
weitere Sporthalle auf er fordert mehr
Hilfe aus Berlin dennoch im März soll
das umstrittene Containerdorf in Upahl
öffnen nächsten Freitag lädt der Kreis
die Bürger zum Dialog ein
jetzt zum Wintersport Norbert da gab es
jede Menge rudelmedaillen für die
Deutschen ja wie heißt das doch so schön
Auftakt nach Maß bei der heimwehm in
Oberhof allen voran Rode
Rekordweltmeister Felix Loch seinen
allerersten WM Sieg hatte er dort vor 15
Jahren eingefahren heute war es dann
insgesamt 14 Titel
es war ein sehr emotionaler Sieg für
Felix Loch der in dieser nach
olympischen Saison wieder zu alter
Stärke gefunden hat ja mir fehlen die
Worte und ähm ja zusammen mit der
Familie mit meinen ganzen Fans ist
einfach hammer zu perfekten Auftrag in
dieser Heim WM ergänzen dann aber noch
die Frauen im Einsitzer mit einem
dreifach Erfolg umweltmeisterin der Jana
Heidberger eine Winzigkeit von einem
Tausendstel liegt sie vor Julia taubets
doch damit nicht genug für zwei weitere
Goldmedaillen sorgen die Doppelsitzer
Eggert Benecken bei den Männern und
Degenhard Rosenthal bei den Frauen
ja und auch bei der skeleton WM in St
Moritz gab es Gold für Deutschland
Susanne Kreher gewann nach vier Läufen
mit einer hundertstel Sekunde Vorsprung
vor der Niederländerin Kimberly Bosch
Hockey Krimi bei der WM in Indien
Deutschland gewinnt im Halbfinale gegen
klar favorisierte Australier mit 4:3
dank eines grandiosen endspurtes
inklusive last minute
die deutschen Hocke Herren wieder mit
Comeback Qualitäten wieder im Rückstand
diesmal gegen den Weltranglisten ersten
Australien das nur zu zweit zweimal
kommt Deutschland zurück in einer puren
strafbecken Partie der Ausgleich zum
zwei zu zwei aber Australien geht wieder
in Führung 57 Minute drei zu zwei doch
der unnahmliche deutsche Argentina
gonzale bea hat leicht aus sein drittes
Tor und wir dann zum Vorlagengeber
goldrichtig steht nicht das Wellen das
4:3 für Deutschland 6 Sekunden vor
Schluss der zweimalige Weltmeister zum 5
mal in einem WM-Finale
und das Finale am Sonntag gegen Belgien
und noch ein Krimi habe ich bei der
Handball WM im ersten Platzierungsspiel
das DHB-Team besiegt Ägypten denkbar
knapp nach Verlängerung Julian Köster
zum 35 zu 34 eine Minute vor Schluss ja
und dann hält Thormann Andreas Wolf er
wird später zum Player of the match
gekürzt Deutschland trifft im Spiel und
Platz 5 auf Ungarn oder Norwegen
und das Spiel live zu sehen bei uns im
ZDF
gemacht
vielen Dank Norbert zum Wetter so viel
es gibt endlich wieder ein bisschen
Sonne morgen Einzelheiten gleich von
ostendali das heute journal wie jeden
Freitag um 22 Uhr dann mit Christian
Sievers von uns war es das morgen hier
Barbara Hellweg für Sie einen
entspannten Start ins Wochenende und auf
bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter vorübergehend
ruhiges Wetter stellt sich ein mit
diesem kleinen hoch was uns
vorübergehend besucht allerdings kommt
auch noch ein Tief zu Besuch und zwar
dieses hier bei Island am Montag
erreicht es uns bringt teils Graupel
Gewitter viel Wind Regen und Schnee mit
es wird ziemlich ungemütlich ruhiger die
kommende Nacht im Südosten gibt es viele
Wolken es schneit ein wenig Glätte
inklusive sonst bildet sich nach Norden
hin sogar Nebel die Temperaturen sinken
auf -6 Grad nach Osten hin und in
Schleswig-Holstein und zwei Grad
Richtung Rhein mein Gebiet morgen im
Südosten Richtung Bayern vor allem auch
letzte Schneefälle lässt allmählich nach
sonst vom Rheinland bis nach Berlin hier
auf Lockerungen mit teilweise viel
Sonnenschein das bei höchsten
Temperaturen von -4 Grad Richtung
Vogtland und fünf Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein die nächsten Tage der
Sonntag erst einmal relativ ruhig bei -2
bis 7 Grad aber Montag geht es dann zur
Sache mit sturmschauern und Gewittern
und dazu Schnee an den Alpen und damit
ein schöner Abend